it's been called a turning point for the
planet and the beginning of the end of
call president xi jinping has said china
will stop funding coal-fired power
plants abroad he made the announcement
in a pre-recorded message to the u.n
general assembly in new york
china will strive to peak carbon dioxide
emissions before 2030 and achieve carbon
neutrality before 2060.
this requires tremendous hard work and
we will make every effort to meet these
goals
china will step up support for other
developing countries
in developing green and low carbon
energy
and will not build new coal-fired power
projects abroad
beijing is the only significant funder
of overseas gold left in the world it
finances some 13
of coal-fired capacity outside of china
now among the countries in asia
receiving funding are indonesia vietnam
pakistan india and bangladesh
private sang is a senior policy advisor
at the european climate think tank e3g
and joins me now from london but i said
how significant is this announcement for
reducing global emissions
yeah it's indeed a very significant
announcement and it's a step forward
in china's climate policy and it shows
that yet again the ties are turning
against core power internationally so at
the beginning of the year we saw that
china south korea and japan were still
major financier of co-power projects
abroad and internationally and over the
course of the year we saw the dominoes
fell one by one with japan and south
korea pledging that they would no longer
use public money to finance coal power
plants overseas and china has obviously
made the same announcement uh last night
and
now china joins the ranks of these major
financials committed to an end to call
which created a great momentum for uh
the classical climate summit in coming
november so the significance about this
announcement is that um it would dry up
co-finance uh internationally because a
lot of the
projects for example in southeast asia
um
is being funded by chinese capital and a
lot of time this capital is being used
to unlock the risk of these projects
which will then bring in more more
private investors into these projects so
um with this announcement uh we
will be seeing an end to
a lot of projects uh in 20 countries
which adds up to
about like 40 gigawatts of core power
which is equivalent to the size of the
coal power fleet in the entire of
germany so this is how significant this
is
yeah it's it's a it's a pretty big
impact this is going to have but then
speaking about those southeast asian
countries particularly countries like
indonesia and vietnam for example
where coal-fired power plants were being
financed by the chinese what does this
lack of chinese financing now mean for
these countries
yeah so i mean like i said because a lot
of times chinese capital uh especially
public money is used to unlock uh
risks for this investment which would
then pave way to other private
investments so now without that those a
lot of projects would not take off
but what is also significant about
chinese announcement yesterday is also
the fact that mr xi has pledged euro
step-up financing for uh
other forms of energy renewable energy
green energy such as solar and wind so
so obviously china will also be playing
a role in the power sector in these
countries uh and the other thing we
should note is that the economics is
turning against coal i mean coal is
becoming
very unprofitable in countries so the
economics is also changing so even with
chinese finance um the economic
is changing and we will see a reduction
of coal in these countries anyway and
also these countries including indonesia
vietnam and also bangladesh
they have second note in the last year
that they're going to
phase out uh their core power in one way
or another so i mean the demand from
these countries also waning and then the
support for renewable power in this
country will be increasing and hopefully
from chinese uh financiers as well
we'll leave it there for the time being
but thank you so much for that
description bye for zang from london